first pitch on the way half drives one
in the air toward right field that is
deep in the corner that's going to be
one hop short hop in the wall
playing it as castiano sits a leadoff
double for ian happ that's the first
extra base hit by a left-handed batter
all season against tyler malley yeah
it's first hit for hap against tyler
malley had been over 12 coming into this
one lead off double
let's see if that leads to bigger and
better things chris bryant coming up
bryant had that epic five for five game
back in 2016 in this park three homers
and two doubles he pulls the ground ball
that's fair bouncing down into the left
field corner a run will score bryant is
going to end up with at least a double
as the throw comes in from winker after
two pitches the cubs lead one to nothing
how about that for an ambush two pitches
in double double toil and trouble for
o'malley trevor williams on the hill for
the cubs joey vado a 387 hitter against
trevor williams
that is smoked into right center field
wave is on for winker half gathers
pirouettes and throws to second winker
scores castellanos claims third rbi base
hit joey votto tie game at one
mustache is willing to go the other way
if he's pitched there
a one
that is grounded left side
duffy baez
in time double play castillano scores
and the reds take the lead a 2-1
advantage trevor williams can really
help himself out man it's second and
third one down
williams swings broken back ground ball
to first scooped up by votto he steps on
the bag as horner scores and williams
helps himself out tying the game at two
gets the rbi on the ground out
one ball two strikes runner home the
ball's there slide safe
he slid under the tag and the cubs take
a 3-2 lead
now they go to the headsets did backup
catcher tony walters just steal home
plate to take the lead so it's either
2-2
going bottom two
where the ending continues and the cubs
have the lead
out
and it's tied
bryant had a double and drove in a run
in the first inning chris drives one in
the air toward left field back toward
the wallet's got a chance gone
home run for bryant cubs lead three to
two
well there you go there's an early
attack he's seen two pitches today he
has doubled in homer and that's been a
big part of his story up there ready to
go early if he gets something to his
liking why not take a whack at it
and his
impressive season continues man he is
just
so much fun to watch the run in cubs
lead by a run and the batter is anthony
rizzo
he hits a high fly ball right center
field and deep back toward the wall gone
anthony rizzo with a home run and the
cubs lead four to two
i believe we have a trend here with all
these first pitch swings it's been
quite a show by the cub hitters today
ambushing tyler o'malley they're just
not letting him settle in castillanos
had a ground ball single up the middle
his first time
swings 3-0 and drills it a high fly he
crushed it
tie game gets the fastball shows the
patience and shows the power mike
mustakis will stand in
mustacha scolds this one to right
hayward looks on gone
the reds lead
third home run of the year for mustaches
his first since coming off the il
he wanted more and so does suarez are
you kidding
he connects and plumbers it
off the red's bump head
career hit number 800
[Applause]
it's home run derby at great american
ballpark
no doubt about it
that's the best batted ball of the day
106.3 off the bat
426 feet chris bryant rbi double and a
homer
chris drops one in the air deep left
field this ball's got a chance it's gone
his second of the day double dinger
dinger so far today and mally again with
the head drops i've got no clue that's a
cement mixer right there
warner drove in the winning run
yesterday trying to drive in the tying
run right now
and that's what he's done with a live
drive down the left field line the time
run is in nico going for two
and the throw to second base not nearly
in time stand up double ball game tied
at six are you ready for this joey votto
bases loaded
strikes out swinging on a changeup reds
left him loaded twice yesterday
way inside and hit him and the reds take
the lead suarez two hits today just his
second multi-hit game
of the year
[Applause]
ground ball through
base hit
winker scores castellano's green light
the throw home too tall castigato
advances to second but now there are two
down maybe javi will hit a home run the
2-2
swing of the drive deep right center
it's got a chance long gone
bias with a long home run to the right
of dead center and the cubs are down by
only one it's nine to eight man on first
tucker barnhart at the plating 3-1
smash to right field hayward back
bye-bye baseball tucker barnhart
11-8
this reds team began the day leading
baseball in run scored
castellanos stings one to right field
and another the fourth hit the second
homer of a stellar day for nick
castellanos
five
homers for the reds it's 12-8
in the air shallow right falling in
there for a base hit this will drive in
a run
and send walters to third rbi single it
is now 12 to 9. now if hap gets on the
plot would really thicken the one two
deep right field this is gonna tie the
game
a three-round homer by ian happ
it's 12 to 12.
the 2-0 lifted the shallow center half
coming in going out his horner horner
makes the catch half is hurt
a collision between the center fielder
and the second baseman
reds and cubs fan alike round of
applause for ian half and why not extra
innings in the finale now garrett is on
facing jason hayward
swing in the miss
2-2
swing and a miss he struck him out
back-to-back sliders for the man to
third castillanos grounded out against
kimbrell yesterday looking for a
five-hit day
2-1
kicks away
winker an open path to third ball went
into the reds dugout so winker has to
stop at third base with a man at third
we're gonna have a five-man infield
3-1
poke to center field the reds win
well once again
nick castellanos being a leader on the
field getting the job done what a ball
game